it's time now for our seen an unseen
segment where we expose what's behind
the big cultural stories of the day he
calls himself a comedian Sacha Baron
Cohen and he pranked everyone from Sarah
Palin to Ted Koppel but could his stunts
now land them in legal trouble for more
were joined by Fox News contributor New
York Times bestselling author of The
Wheel Wilder series Raymond Arroyo
Raymond Cohen's new show who is America
premiered this weekend but the real
question is I want to know is who the
heck is watching not too many people it
premiered with only three hundred and
twenty seven thousand total viewers
that's point one in the demo if you had
those ratings you would probably go into
a retirement well I bet in 303 am I get
those I don't even think you get him at
3m I think you get more than that but
here's here's the point though Cohen was
able to snooker people like Dick Cheney
Sarah Palin and others there was a
Riverside California gun shop owner whom
when Cohen walked in his name was Norris
Sweden the gun shop owner he saw through
Sasha's charade early on watch I just
kept looking at the guy and I was like
you're Borat as soon as I said that his
I just looked at me like and he did Abby
turned right out the door once I knew
was Borat we already know his game in
his so we knew that he's here to make a
mockery and make a mockery of what gun
owners the gun business gun shops he
didn't make a mockery of gun owners and
gun activists he got some of them to
read a script teaching children how to
use firearms again it's to embarrass
people who own guns like guns and by the
way was dressed as a Hungarian immigrant
there with the beard he looked like a
runaway from duck they make fun of the
good old boys like the good old boys are
dumb and that good old boys all right
through that lame costume and in little
fraidy cat instead of staying there
trying to do some original stand-up call
you should have turned it into a joke
but instead he ran out a little and it
was charges hold what he's stolen valor
in fact there was some billboards around
la about this the problem with The
Stolen Valor Act of 2013 that something
applies to Cohen because he impersonated
a
war veteran it doesn't apply you have
it's about wearing the medal of false
medal that's what's the electric he's
impersonating a comedian myself there's
a new Ruth Bader Ginsburg biopic you're
already got your ticket I'm ready ready
ready on the in it's called on the basis
of sex that's just it's is that the joke
no that's not it's coming under fire for
potential inaccuracies what are they
well first of all portraying Ruth Bader
Ginsburg is an actress named Felicity
Jones I'll put up a picture of them
aside by side so you can compare do you
think this evokes Ruth Bader Ginsburg
I'll leave it to the audience but the
bigger the bigger Pro it's the doily
that's all they both beautiful in there
yes if Felicity Jones had the doily it
would be better Ginsburg it's one of the
nicest people do you know I spent New
Year's Eve with her in 1986 this is a
walk down memory lane
I gotta get to a segment okay here's
what happened they played a trailer of
this movie they've released it and legal
scholars are going crazy watch okay
you think you can change the country we
should look to her generation they're
taking to the streets protests are
important but changing the culture it
means nothing if the law doesn't change
what did you say your name was Ruth
Bader Ginsburg the word woman does not
appear even once in the US Constitution
no what is the word freedom your honor
so the word freedom doesn't appear in
the Constitution I ask you now the
screenwriter who is also Ruth Bader
Ginsburg's nephew surprise surprise he
says it what she's is what she's
pointing to is the Constitution as it
was originally adopted before the Bill
of Rights and that that's why she says
freedom doesn't appear in the original
ones are woodard but they're making fun
of Trump for all I can say is when they
cast my life story I want somebody as
pretty as you know that's speaking oh
you're gonna guess do this now oh okay
I'll do this speaking of gender politics
and equality Barack Obama in
Johannesburg spoke out against his own
sex today watch men have been getting on
my nerves lately I mean I just every day
I read the newspaper and I just think my
brother's what's wrong with you guys I
mean what's wrong with us all right I
mean we're we're violent were bullying
violence and bullying the idea that men
are like a target this is like toxic
masculinity that term that's behind
popular now and then the notion is that
masculinity robust masculinity leads to
bullying or assaults upon women you know
what leads to assaults upon women men
who are not taught to be gentlemen
that's the problem and all these studies
now coming out about the gender
inequality in certain industries like
film they did a study film review
critics okay 68 percent male as opposed
to 32% here well they say this is why
female flicks that have all-female cast
like ages no not that
ghostbusters oceans 8 all the female
reboots that story they flop because
they get bad reviews at all of it men
well I looked at publishing an industry
I know a lot about 6 78 percent of the
people in publishing are women ok we
have to equalize that more middle
be hired I'm gonna tell you what I've
worked with a lot of these women you
know why they're there not because
they're women because they're good
they're good they're details that should
be in these positions we should not be
worrying about gender equity pounds
people are better in some professions
and others leave it alone I think I'm
gonna get one of those doilies around
mine every night and I never liked the
doilies a Sandra Day O'Connor started it
and it keeps going no no I always want
to grip grab avaaz and put it on reminds
me that thing my grandmother always had
that on the back of the car right
exactly those are never cleaned